on a le sentiment que c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes
quel est votre constat la menace
terroriste est une menace pour le bas et
que sa réponse également doit être plus
souvent et la solidarité au bas
[Musique]
la bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 17 février
arrivé par surprise aussitôt rejetée par
la commission du sénat l'amendement du
gouvernement qui devait permettre le
vote par anticipation pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 devrait
connaître le même sort demain dans
l'hémicycle outre le vote par
anticipation ce sont aussi les machines
à voter qui font grincer des dents
plusieurs pays d'europe utilise pourtant
ce procédé
[Musique]
un rien peut faire basculer
la situation l'avertissement ce matin du
porte parole du gouvernement dans la
foulée d'un nouveau conseil de défense
autour d' emmanuel macron pas de
reconfirme en vue mais un appel à
poursuivre les efforts alors que les
hôpitaux sont toujours fortement
sollicité les contaminations reste
stable partout dans le monde le msp et
état d'une chute de 16 % des nouveaux
cas de e que vides toute l'europe sur le
pont face au virus nouvel accord annoncé
par ursula von der leyen pour acheter
300 millions de doses supplémentaires du
vexin moderna est critiquée pour sa
lenteur ou pour les ratés de la
vaccination la commission a dévoilé le
même jour un plan pour mieux surveiller
les mutations du coronavirus un projet
baptisé ra incubator
[Musique]
moyens de lutter contre l'abstention
pour la majorité manoeuvre électoraliste
pour l'opposition léman nom qui vise à
permettre le vote par anticipation en
2022 est loin de faire l'unanimité au
sénat
le palais du luxembourg examine en ce
moment l'examen du projet de loi relatif
à l'organisation de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
nadège abderrazak la méthode a été
décrié outre atlantique elle a été
utilisée dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire pour l'organisation des
élections présidentielles américaines
donald trump grand perdant du scrutin a
fini par crier à la fraude électorale
et pourtant le vote électronique
pourrait prochainement débarquer en
france
vous l'aurez peut être deviné chez nous
sommes au sénat qui examine en ce moment
même le projet de loi sur l'organisation
de l'élection présidentielle de 2022
et c'est dans ce contexte précis que le
gouvernement a présenté à la toute
dernière minute ce mardi un amendement
pour organiser le vote anticipé des
électeurs dans un certain nombre de
collectivités sur des machines à voter
ce vote serait une alternative au vote
par procuration est il interviendrait
dans la semaine précédant le scrutin dès
2022 si les parlementaires le décide
voici ce que dit le texte le jour du
scrutin à 19 heures le président du
bureau de vote rend visible les
compteurs totalisant les suffrages
exprimés par chaque candidat ainsi que
les votes blancs de manière à en
permettre la lecture par les membres du
bureau de vote les délégués des
candidats et les électeurs présents des
garanties seraient prévues pour éviter
un double vote les résultats ne seraient
dépouillés que le soir de l'élection
comme pour les bureaux de vote
ordinaires et garanties loin d'être
suffisante pour la majorité de droite
ici au sénat qui devrait rejeter cet
amendement
bruno retailleau chef de file des
républicains ici au palais du luxembourg
dénonce même une magouille politicienne
de la part de l'est
c'est un amendement qui est venu
précipitamment sans que le conseil
d'état n'ait pu examiner sa portée sans
que nous mêmes nous ayons pu faire un
travail parlementaire approfondie c'est
en catimini et ça ça évoque évidemment
des soupçons puis c'est surtout l'aspect
beaucoup plus du fond puisque les
électeurs ne sont pas en situation
d'égalité il y à des électeurs urbains
qui seront tout près des machines à
voter et d'autres qui sont très loin à
1h 2h 3h aller retour de du centre du
département et donc yann comment
dirais-je une égalité de traitement et
ça pose un sujet d'ailleurs d'ordre
constitutionnel puis un autre sujet
qu'elle la sincérité du scrutin
pourquoi parce que on voit bien que si
vous votez le mercredi et qu' il se
passe un bouleversement un événement
énorme entre le mercredi et le dimanche
de l'élection
vous avez peut-être envie de changer
votre vie mais vous ne le pourrait pas
et de plus en plus on voit bien que les
votes se cristallisent tardivement donc
là aussi un vrai problème et ça n'est
pas une méthode de toute façon cette
précipitation cache en réalité je le
pense malheureusement une manoeuvre
électorale visant avantage est peut-être
un peu plus la participation d'un
électorat dont on suppose qu'il est plus
proche de monsieur ma crainte que
d'autres candidats voilà cet amendement
doit être soumis ce jeudi au palais du
luxembourg en séance publique le vote
électronique serait une première à
l'échelle nationale des machines à voter
sont en effet utilisés localement à
palavas-les-flots notamment mais elles
restent marginales dans le système
électoral français
d'autant que depuis 2008 un moratoire
limité leur usage aux collectivités qui
en disposent alors alternative au vote
par procuration huit pays européens en
tout cas pratique déjà ce vote par
anticipation
alors quelles seraient les a tous ses
atouts à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 pts ils permettent de faire
baisser l'abstention alors que
l'opposition elle y voit clairement une
manoeuvre politique c'est l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en débattre philippe
laurent maire rudy de saut vous êtes
également secrétaire général de
l'association des maires de france
bonsoir philippe laurent merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés pour débattre
valérie boyer sénatrice l ère des
bouches du rhône
bonsoir valérie boyer merci d'être avec
nous alors si l'amendement était adoptée
par le parlement ce serait évidemment
une une première dans notre pays le vote
par anticipation serait alors mis en
place pour une échéance très importante
la présidentielle de 2000 22 valérie
boyer on imagine à l'instar de votre
groupe vous allez à voter contre 1 jeudi
demain c'est à dire pour quelle raison
bien sûr que je vais voter contre demain
jeudi et je serai dans l'hémicycle pour
défendre notre point de vue écoutez
c'est choquant sur le fond et la forme
c'est choquant sur la forme parce que
cet amendement arrive en catimini au
décours d'une loi tout à fait banale sur
l'organisation des élections
c'est choquant sur le fond parce que ça
nous est vendu comme voulant lutter
contre l'abstention or je prends
l'exemple du dernier scrutin
présidentiel
sauf erreur de ma part je crois que 87 %
des électeurs sont allés aux urnes pour
les deux tours ou un détour de la
présidentielle et pour les législatives
donc on voit bien que ce n'est pas le
problème d'abstention pour ce scrutin
ensuite ce qui est choquant c'est que le
conseil constitutionnel à plusieurs
reprises a mis en garde contre les
machines à voter si un moratoire c'est
pas pour rien et nous vendre ça comme un
moyen de lutter contre l'abstention mais
c'est juste de la mauvaise foi un signe
puisque le gouvernement l'a refusée par
l'organisation des régionales et
départementales
donc c'est très troublant de voir à quel
point le président de la république est
sans cesse en train de modifier les
règles du jeu en fait on dirait que ne
pouvant gagner à la loyale
il faut qu'il modifie les règles du jeu
pour s'assurer de sa réélection
et alors il est certain que c'est un
petit peu consubstantiels au maquereau
nisme on se souvient que emmanuel macron
a été élu parce que il n'ya pas eu de
débat sur la présidentielle parce que la
présidentielle a été le débat de la
présidentielle a été volée au français
s'est substituée à ce débat le procès de
françois fillon
donc il a été élu sur cette espèce de
malentendus et depuis on n'a de cesse
que de bouleverser et de désorganiser la
vie politique française sur le plan
institutionnel et même sur le plan
politique et la façon dont cet
amendement a été présenté et son
objectif qui est complètement fausse a
peut être pour lutter contre
l'abstention et bien évidemment nous
fait penser à une suspicion de
tripatouillage de magouilles et puis
c'est extrêmement grossier pour les élus
pour le parlement pour les mères qui
sont mis devant le fait accompli
donc il y aurait une centaine de merde
en dedans urbains dans des villes qui
disposerait dans les préfectures d'un
bureau de vote avec une machine à voter
alors ça n'a rien de moderne la machine
à voter un ca existe depuis les années
60 et ça avait été retiré et puis à les
autres j'allais dire 20 a les pauvres
ceux qui ne sont rien peut-être les
gaulois réfractaires qui n'ont pas la
chance d'avoir deux machines à voter qui
vont devoir y aller le dimanche
et tout cela en voudront pas partir en
week-end ou qu'ils ne prendront pas la
peine de déposer une procuration ou de
s'organiser pour la procuration qui
auront sur la machine à voter c'est à
demander l'avis du maire justement
philippe laurent vous partagez cette
opinion de valérie boyer philippe lors
on va vous redonner la parole vous
inquiétez pas valérie boyer philippe
laurent vous partager cette opinion pour
ou contre le vote par anticipation
oui alors moi je ne me prononce ni pour
ni contre pour l'instant ce qui
m'apparaît absolument désastreux est ce
que ce qu'elle dit valérie boyer
d'ailleurs c'est que en réalité tout
ceci est venue au dernier moment ça
concerne quand même un élément tout à
fait essentiel sur lequel les maires ou
une responsabilité qui est le vote
l'opération de vote en en elle-même
l'association des maires de france a dit
sa stupéfaction devant cette offre cette
affaire parce que nous n'avons pas été
ni consultés ni prévenu ni quoi que ce
soit c'est venu d'un seul coup comme ça
et je pense d'ailleurs que les sénateurs
eux mêmes ont été assez stupéfait de
cette façon de faire ça n'est vraiment
pas une façon de faire et je voudrais
vraiment souligner à notre sujet c'est
que ça c'est fait pour l'élection
présidentielle
mais lorsqu'il ya eu le débat sur les
élections départementales et régionales
il ya quelques semaines nous avons
proposé l'association des maires de
france
les parlementaires sont deux
parlementaires ont proposé que soit
remis en vigueur la double procuration
c'est à dire le fait qu'une qu'un
électeur puisse avoir deux procurations
ça avait été le cas au moment des
élections municipales
on a proposé un certain nombre
d'améliorations au système pour que
précisément ces élections
départementales et régionales puissent
donner lieu à une participation
convenable et ça n'a pas été accepté par
le gouvernement alors vraiment on se dit
que vraiment je vous assure c'est un
coup de la colère pour pour nous parce
que nous nous disons finalement que du
mépris que veut faire les disait que
veut faire du gouvernement il veut que
la participation aux régionales et
départementales de la majorité
présidentielle a quand même de bonnes
chances de perdre
soit le minimal à 1000 m2 le plus la
plus basse possible pour décrédibiliser
ces élections alors même que sur
l'élection présidentielle ont fait tout
ce qu'il faut pour augmenter la
participation dont il ya un vrai sujet
moi je trouve que franchement là on va
trop loin
on joue trop avec l'expression
démocratique de nos concitoyens
effectivement c'est un peu sorti du
chapeau et ça a fait réagir pas que pas
que vous en savez ressort réagir surtout
les politiques à droite on va écouter
ces réactions vont de vous redonner la
parole
ils n'ont pas le temps d'instaurer la
proportionnelle maison tant de
magouilles et un vote anticipé pour nous
c'est hors de question
élection présidentielle le gouvernement
veut organiser par un amendement de
dernière minute déposé au sénat 1
vote dans 100 villes sur machines
électroniques plusieurs jours avant le
dimanche du scrutin improvisation
bricolage graves atteintes aux règles
démocratiques
rappelons qu'avant le vote anticipé sur
la machine à voter les maquereaux nist
avait déjà tenté un coup de force sur le
retour du vote par correspondance
y compris le 15 janvier par amendement
parlementaire toujours par souci de
notre santé et de la participation bien
sûr alors on vient d'en parler justement
à ce côté sortie du du chapeau de
dernière minute qui fait réagir mais
dans le fond valérie boyer voyez que
recherche le gouvernement
finalement ça des favoriserait plutôt la
république en marche et ça ferait
peut-être basculé dans les extrêmes
entre guillemets écoutez ça j'en sais
rien mais c'est vrai qu'après le débat
le débat le duo de gérald darmanin avec
marine le pen où chacun et l'assurance
vie de l'autre on voit bien qu'il ya une
sorte de dialogue et d'une de collusion
qui s'installe entre eux mais là on est
dans la politique sur le plan de
l'égalité des électeurs
l'esprit de la vème république c'est la
rencontre d'un homme ou d'une femme
avec le peuple si le s'il n'y a pas une
communion nationale le jour de
l'élection présidentielle
comment voulez-vous faire en sorte que
les français s'intéressent plus à la
politique c'est quand même très
important que une fois tous les cinq ans
on puisse se déplacer ensemble pour
choisir qui va être le président de la
république moi je trouve que c'est
extrêmement important
ensuite mon collègue a entièrement
raison sur le fait que ce qu'il propose
là vient de nous être refusé pour
d'autres scrutins par le gouvernement
donc ça suffit les magouilles
moi je pense qu'il est qu'il faut que
emmanuel macron cesse d'abîmer les
institutions on ne peut pas sans arrêt
donner des coups de boutoir au parlement
au maire regardez comment emmanuel
macron avait procédé avec le grand débat
en passant par dessus la tête des maires
c'était pas un grand débat d'ailleurs il
n'en est rien ressorti c'était un grand
monologue
suite au fiasco des gilet jaune qu'il
avait provoqué là on est encore devant
un mépris du parlement puisque on essaye
de torpiller l'examen d'un texte en
présentant de façon totalement anormal
un amendement qui n'a pas de sens ni
pour ni pour lutter contre l'abstention
et qui n'a rien de moderne puisque c'est
quelque chose qui existe depuis les
années 60 comme je vous disais et que le
conseil constitutionnel recommande de
stopper parce que il y a des suspicions
de fraude et parce que on n'arrive pas
de sécuriser le vote
alors quel est l'intérêt si ce n'est de
jeter du trouble et ensuite comment on
imagine une campagne électorale avec des
gens qui vont s'arrêter le mercredi et
d'autres qui vont aller jusqu'au
dimanche mais c'est pas possible et
pourquoi valérie boyer le vote anticipé
existe dans plusieurs pays européens on
va on va les voir huit pays européens
précisément l'appliquent à tous les
électeurs dont le portugal regarder la
suisse le danemark
mais la norvège suède finlande estonie
et lettonie ce il ya quand même des
démocraties là dedans alors pourquoi pas
nous philippe laurent
écoutez chaque pays vous savez à son
histoire démocratique chaque pays a ses
traditions
chaque pays a sa culture démocratique en
france ont réagi en france c'est vrai
que l'élection présidentielle est devenu
à un moment de communion nationale n'ont
pas forcément autour des candidats mais
autour de l'idée que l'ensemble des
français donc élise et donc se présenter
à un public qui a comme vous le savez
des pouvoirs absolument fin très
important peut-être d'ailleurs trop
important maintenant c'est autre chose
donc il ya des pouvoirs en tout cas
important mais donc par conséquent c'est
devenu l'élection reine et donc notre
notre démocratie notre république
elle dit clairement cette histoire
culturelle démocratique elle dit voilà
tout le monde va voter en même temps à
un jour donné il y as si vous voulez
vous le savez avant le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle le débat entre
les deux candidats qui restent en lice
il ya tout ça ça fait partie tout à
l'heure en général
la page dans le bruit en retard dans le
reportage disent eh bien voilà
l'élection présidentielle elle se fait
jusqu'au bout il ya des débats il y à
des événements qui peuvent survenir et
donc le vote doit avoir lieu quand tout
le monde le même jour ou alors il faut
qu' on est un très grand débat entre
nous ça va prendre du temps mais
pourquoi pas sur tout le système
on peut revoir tout le système nous on
n'est pas opposé à ce qu'on discute du
système pour voir est-ce que l'on peut
le modifier mais on ne peut pas de
modifier comme ça par petits coups qui
arrivent comme sa matinale matutine
allemands comme on dit par un amendement
du gouvernement enfin tout ça est
absurde
vous savez à projet de loi ça doit
donner lieu à une étude d'impact ça
c'est la règle si les deux couleurs
galère en réalité les gouvernements
parce que tous les gouvernements l'ont
fait il faut être clair maintenant au
dépôt d'un projet de loi et puis si on
veut ajouter un truc enfin avant de
vancouver le mental et cet amendement ne
donne pas lieu à l'étude d'impact tout
ça ne va pas notre système là ne
fonctionne plus plus bien et donc nous
les maires qui sommes sur le terrain des
gens pragmatiques ou bien nous nous
voyons cela
avec un peu de désespérance et comme je
le disais tout à l'heure avec aussi un
peu de colère
tout ça ne va pas on ne va pas
reconstruire la république comme ça ça
sera le mot de la fin pour vous est ce
que ça montre en tout cas une certaine
forme de fébrilité dans le dans le camp
de la mecque ronnie en vue des
présidentielles
en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne
ah oui je pense que oui parce que si je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure combien les
propositions très simple que nous avons
fait pour améliorer la situation du parc
de la participation lors des élections
départementales et régionales avaient
été refusées et pour nous ce sont des
élections aussi qui sont très
importantes être concernent la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens et donc
on ne comprend pas pourquoi tout ça a
été refusé à ce moment là depuis que
tout à coup on s'aperçoit qu'ils aient
des élections présidentielles qui
arrivent et or très vite il faut
modifier les règles du jeu valérie voyez
donc fébrilité de la part du
dukan micron la présidentielle et a bel
et bien démarré brigitte et oui oui
fébrilité et aussi cette méthode comme
le disait monsieur laurent le maire de
sceaux qui consiste systématiquement à
modifier les règles du jeu comme si
emmanuel macron se considérer comme
incapable de gagner à la loyale avec des
règles communément admise en fait il est
là pour en sorte déconstruire la vème
république
c'est pas de mandat qu'il a eu des
français est aujourd'hui un parlement il
ya l'union des maires qui s'opposent à
ceux à ce dispositif au sénat tous les
groupes ont voté contre et à l'assemblée
nationale il faut quand même savoir est
rappelé que même dans le camp macro nist
eh bien il ya des députés qui étaient
contre donc à un moment donné je pense
que nos institutions surtout dans une
période de grande fragilité comme la
nôtre ça se respecte et que peut-être
que d'autres pays ont mis en place du
vote anticipé mais chez nous l'élection
du président de la république
si ce jour là on n'est pas capable
d'organiser pour tout le monde
un vote à égalité avec un débat comme
monsieur laurent vient de le rappeler
qui a lieu en général le mercredi ou le
jeudi avant avant le scrutin pour que
les français puissent se déterminer on
sait très bien qu'ils se déterminent au
dernier moment
et bien c'est qu'on aura encore rater ce
grand moment démocratique écouter on l'a
ratée en 2017
ce serait quand même dramatique qu on le
rate en 2022 une deuxième fois
là on serait vraiment dans une crise
institutionnelle extrêmement forte et
qui serait la responsabilité d'emmanuel
macron donc moi je dis stop à la casse
de la vème république l'élection
présidentielle ça ne se joue pas en
catimini à travers un amendement qui est
déposé en douce pour modifier
profondément la relation du président de
la république avec les français merci à
tous les deux merci à tous les deux
philippe laurent valérie boyer d'avoir
été avec nous merci et direction à
présent barcelone où la colère gronde
depuis l'incarcération d'un rappeur
pablo azy
à qui a été condamné à neuf mois de
prison pour des tweets dans lesquelles
ils insultaient les forces de l'ordre
espagnoles et s'en prenait à la
monarchie pour plus de précision dont je
trouve trouvons en direct sur arte
france notre correspondante à barcelone
leslie singh là bonsoir leslie vous êtes
justement aucun de cette manifestation
en manifestation contre l'arrestation du
rapport du rappeur oui exactement et ce
soir c'est plus qu'une manifestation
contre l'arrestation du rappeur seth une
manifestation pour la liberté
d'expression les manifestants ont scandé
liberté tableau alors le symbole a été
hachée aussi par un manifeste il ya
quelques jours 200 personnalités du
monde de la culture ont signé un
manifeste pour défendre le rappeur ils
demandent surtout que les excès verbaux
commis lors de lors de manifestations
culturelles intellectuelles soient
exclus du code pénal afin d'exclure les
peines de prison alors de son côté le
gouvernement espagnol a même avoué qu'il
était nécessaire de réformer par la voie
la plus rapide possible
les délits touchant à la liberté
d'expression alors en tout cas ce soir
les manifestants ne veulent rien lâcher
je vous propose de les écouter
l'espagne devrait agir comme tout autre
pays d'europe et démocratiquement je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ce que fait
l'espagne avec pablo à sel et avec la
liberté d'expression d'autres artistes
c'est une honte de la part d'un état qui
ne fait que réprimer les gens que ce
soit pour les chanteurs ou les
responsables politiques et les c'est
suite aux émeutes de la veille est ce
qu'un dispositif a été appliquée
alors vite puisque la tension est à son
comble un vaste dispositif policier a
été déployé les forces de l'ordre
catalan ont expliqué qu'elles ont
travaillé sur le sujet toute la journée
l'objectif est d'éviter toute forme de
violence et le cas échéant de pouvoir
agir très rapidement alors les autorités
souhaitent éviter une soirée similaire à
celle vécue lors de la première journée
de manifestations des milliers de
personnes étaient sortis dans la rue il
y avait donc eu des émeutes à barcelone
des banques et commerces avaient été
vandalisés des containers brûlés des
barricades montées le bilan a été de 30
manifestants blessés 25 policiers
blessés 18 personnes arrêtées et 20 à
barcelone 70 euros de dégâts alors le
ministère de l'intérieur catalan s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui en avertissant que
la violence ne peut pas garantir les
droits fondamentaux et qu'il serait
obligé de l'arrêter
la demande est un bon millier de
manifestants d'aujourd'hui de faire une
manifestation pacifique
merci les glycines laon direct de
barcelone rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reparlerons du covin
nouveau conseil de défense ce matin
aucune mesure exceptionnelle annoncée
mais le porte parole du gouvernement
alerte nous pourrions payer très cher
tout relâchement
et puis direction les autres pays
européens un nouvel accord annoncé par
ursula von der leyen pour acheter 300
millions de doses supplémentaires du
vexin moderna
[Musique]
on
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous un oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça valait il
faut que le rck est regroupée
la musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie soumettait pas la vie
va évidemment on s'embête il faut sortir
les notes de leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
et
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve était
le seul à pouvoir créer un mission d'une
paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abrams resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que nitro la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens ne s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la daube
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la minustah elle compte au moins
quatorze mille militaires et policiers
déployés au mali n'ont fait elle face
c'est une mission de paix et la chose
unis mais la vérité c'est qu'elle évolue
dans un environnement difficile comme
avant un ennemi un ennemi invisible
un ennemi qui ne connaît pas de
frontières qui le premier cas la
brutalité qui la concerne
dumas mais grâce à notre détermination
nous sommes très différents
on a le sentiment c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes
quel est votre constat la menace
terroriste et d' une menace globale et
que sa réponse également doit être plus
souvent la de la solidarité
aubin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fall de l'apli pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont l'un des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez sur le
front du coc vide nouveau conseil de
défense se met un autour d' emmanuel
macron aucunes mesures exceptionnelles
annoncées mais le porte parole du
gouvernement alerte
nous pourrions payer très cher tout
relâchement gabriela talent qui est
aussi revenu sur la stratégie de
vaccination du gouvernement
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite en direct david khalifa
notre reporter en direct de l'avenue de
ségur bonsoir david alors pas de grande
annonce un le gouvernement garde son cap
rien qui ne changera pas et stéphanie
malgré un très léger très léger
redressement de la situation le porte
parole du gouvernement a salué les
efforts des français
il les encourage à les maintenir en
durant cette période de vacances
scolaires aucune nouvelle la restriction
ne sera prise même dans les zones où le
variant inquiète a faim je cite de
laisser respirer elle est un français
concernant les chiffres dans les
hôpitaux ils sont en baisse la
décroissance de malades duo qu'ovide et
de 14 % sur la semaine le nombre de
malades dans un an dans un état grave se
stabilise et le nombre de morts sur sept
jours en moyenne représente la 300 décès
un quotidien
autre point abordé qui fait tant
polémique la campagne de vaccination
gabriel attal a reconnu qu'elle n'était
pas à la hauteur de la volonté à des
français mais que le gouvernement allait
prendre toutes les dispositions pour
répondre à cette demande écoute et veut
dire aujourd'hui que la mécanique est
bien en route les centres de vaccination
couvre tout le territoire et nous
fonctionnons en flux tendu nous avons
avec l'europe su taper du poing sur la
table et obtenu davantage de doses de
vaccin le président de la république a
mobilisé toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique et dès le mois prochain
des vaccins moderna seront fabriqués et
produit en france à la suite de cette
mobilisation
les trois quarts des résidents en ehpad
reçu une injection et déjà plus de 20 %
des plus de 75 ans ont reçu au moins une
dose du vaccin
nous allons répondre à l'enthousiasmé de
nos aînés et puis par tranche d'âge
ensuite nous attendrons la vaccination à
l'ensemble des français selon le
calendrier la stratégie qui ont été
prévus et annoncés par le gouvernement
près de deux millions cinq cent mille
personnes ont reçu pour le moment une
première dose de vaccin soit 3 3% de la
population
a contrario un peu plus de 900 mille
personnes ont reçu la deuxième dose à un
rythme qui doit donc s'accélérer alors
david les chiffres aux quilles
s'améliore et une campagne de
vaccination qui va s'accélérer mathon
fait entrevoir le bout du tunnel
un rien peut tout faire basculer c'est
sur ce terme qui a mis la table a
insisté c'est pour cela que aucun un
changement de cap n'a été abordée
pourtant elle est française sont
nombreux à se demander quand ils vont
pouvoir retrouver une vie normale
malheureusement ce n'est pas pour tout
de suite le couvre-feu qui devait à la
base d'urée avec quinze jours reste en
vigueur et ne sera pas modifiée tant que
la situation le nécessitera on se dirige
plutôt vers un allègement pas à pas en
ce concentrant en premier lieu sur les
départements les moins touchés certains
membres du gouvernement entendent par
exemple revenir sur la réouverture de
certains lieux publics comme les amuser
à compter du mois de marche
en revanche concernant les restaurants
et les centres commerciaux de plus de 20
millimètres carrés qui sont toujours
fermés ça ne sera pas avant l'été 2021
selon certains à députés pour espérer
une réouverture plus précoce l'exécutif
travaille sur la mise à jour de
l'application a tous senti qu vite
destiné aux restaurants et aux salles de
sport qui permettrait d' alerter
rapidement elle les clients en cas de
cas positifs aux mêmes horaires de
visite
bref vous l'aurez compris le bout du
tunnel ce n'est pas pour tout de suite
merci david khalifa et en moselle où le
variant sud-africain circulent dix fois
plus que sur le reste du territoire le
nombre de cas positifs diminue lentement
la situation critique du 3 février
dernier avec 397 cas pour 100000
habitants a poussé le gouvernement aidé
le département en délivrant trente mille
doses du vaccin pfizer biotech pour
autant la question qu'on se pose faut-il
ou non prioriser à la vaccination pour
les zones les plus touchées
éléments de réponse avec antoine ogier
dix mille doses de vaccin de pfizer sur
les trente mille annoncées par le
gouvernement ont été livrés depuis ce
lundi en moselle dans l'est de la france
comme le ministre de la santé présents à
metz vendredi et s'y était engagé un
effort particulier de solidarité
nationale est accomplie pour la moselle
d'ici deux semaines nous serons
vraisemblablement en tête des
départements où la vaccination est la
plus répandue
un effort particulier est fait pour la
moselle ça tient à la forte présence de
variants dans notre département
les vingt mille doses suivants devraient
être livrés d'ici à la fin de la semaine
mais cette décision de faire passer en
priorité certains départements n'est pas
vue d'un bon oeil par tout le monde avec
une population constituée de près d'un
tiers des seniors le département azuréen
concentre une importante population
vulnérable aux coronavirus et qui ne
peut demeurer dans l'incertitude et
l'angoissé dans la tente de voir son
territoire doté de doses en quantités
suffisantes
aussi je vous prie d'agir immédiatement
pour dotés de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de doses supplémentaires
l'un des départements de france qui
appelle à la solidarité sanitaires
nationales dans le contexte est très
inquiétant qui rencontre alors que le
taux d'incidence est au dessus des 500
cas de contamination pour 100000
habitants à nice et que les services de
réanimation sont occupés à presque 100%
dans les alpes-maritimes
seulement 3% de la population
départementale et vaccinés si la
question de vacciner par incidence pose
des problèmes d'ordre éthique et remet
en cause le principe d'égalité
plusieurs spécialistes recommandent
pourtant d'administrer le vaccin en
priorité dans les régions où le taux
d'incidence est le plus élevé de façon
très pragmatique si l'objectif est
d'éviter des cas des hospitalisations et
des décès on en évitera davantage en
vaccinant les territoires où l'incidence
est plus élevé que dans un territoire où
l'incidence est faible alors que la
pandémie semble faiblir ces derniers
jours sur l'ensemble de la planète
la campagne de vaccination mis en place
en france il y à un mois et demi se
poursuit quant au gouvernement par la
voix de son porte-parole gabriela talent
il rappelle que la stratégie de
vaccination ne devrait pas évoluer dans
l'immédiat les trois quarts des
résidents en ehpad reçu une injection et
déjà plus de 20 % des plus de 75 ans ont
reçu au moins une dose du vaccin
nous allons répondre à l' enthousiasme
nos aînés et puis par tranche d'âge
ensuite nous attendrons la vaccination à
l'ensemble des français selon le
calendrier la stratégie qui ont été
prévus et annoncés par le gouvernement
dans un souci d'égalité territoriales ce
sont donc les personnes âgées ou à
risque les malades du cobp ide et le
personnel médical soit environ 8
millions de français qui vont continuer
de bénéficier des vaccins en priorité en
france ce sont près de 3 millions
d'injections qui ont été effectuées
alors que plus de 80 mille décès liés au
virus sont désormais à déplorer et pour
en parler nous sommes avec damien
allouche maire ps d'epinay sous sénart
dans l'essonne bonsoir damien donc merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
adore ça pose évidemment plein de
questions cette priorisation faut-il
faire passer en premier certains
territoires pour la vaccination ou
évidemment ça revient à faire gagner
l'élue qui parle le plus fort alors
c'est évidemment surtout parce qu'il
faut soit quoi il faut arriver il faut
qu'il y ait une volée il approche
républicaine sur sur la stratégie de
vaccination est évidemment si ces élus
qui craignent plus forte qu'elle plus de
vaccins ou le territoire était le plus
fort qu'elle pût de vaccins alors on a
un souci sur se réfère délit de
vaccination sur le front républicain que
cela implique par exemple
illustration en moselle où on voit qu'il
ya eu des progrès sur le front des
chiffres alors que les les chiffres
étaient vraiment préoccupant le 3
février on a priorisé ça me semble quand
même être logique égalité ou équité de
la république dans ce cas là pour le
coup c'est pas les élus qui ont ils
prêtaient pas les élus concret et plus
fort c'est la demande et l'augmentation
atteint incroyable du nombre de cas et
le virus qui les diffusent encore plus
donc ils vont au ski être en capacité de
pouvoir s'adapter aux situations des
territoires d avoir cette capacité
d'agilité c'est ce qu'on demande depuis
le départ aussi alors cette adaptation
des territoires ça veut dire quoi qu'on
sert avant tout les endroits où le taux
d'incidence est le plus élevé
y'a peut-être le plus de personnes âgées
comment déterminer la priorité selon
vous alors moi je suis ni médecin ni
épidémiologistes donc je m'attache à à
bien suivre les avis et les conseils des
uns des uns et les autres de toute façon
depuis je suis très important justement
vous êtes un homme de terrain
c'est ce qui nous intéresse le plus est
bien j'imagine mais ce que je vais vous
dire par là c'était que healy a
évidemment cette grille de lecture qui
est essentiel à la base et puis ensuite
un échange avec les maires avec les
préfets avec les présidents tous les
présidents de conseil départemental qui
permettra ensuite de définir et de faire
appel si besoin en était en tout cas
d'avoir un des suppléments de deux
vaccins si il y avait une situation qui
se dégrade et localement donc ce que ce
que j'ai fait alors d'avoir la capacité
de répondre précisément à une à une
urgence territoriale ça il faut 100 il
faut se redresser cette liberté mais
c'est pas parce qu'un élu très très fort
et réclamerait à cor et à cri des
vaccins qui en face il ya pas d des
chiffres objective et et vérifiable pour
autant qu'il aura vraiment que cela une
base de chiffres autour du travail des
médecins et des épidémies
alors vous monsieur le maire d'epinay
sous sénart quelle est la situation chez
vous sur le terrain est ce que vous avez
assez de doses
les rendez-vous sont sont possibles chez
vous alors dans ma commune aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le ce n'est pas le cas on
est prêts nous aujourd'hui à accueillir
s'il le fallait
et si on vous appelle à nous on est en
capacité aujourd'hui d'accueillir un
vaccinodromes dans la commune de la
collectivité qui est à côté de la mienne
il ya un acquis au d'euros mais ça se
passe lors des semaines c'est un peu
plus compliqué que d'autres parce que
parfois les doses de vaccin n'arrive pas
telle qu'elle était telle qu'elle est et
a attendu parfois ça va ça va un peu
mieux donc
donc les agents de cette commune sont
obligés un petit peu de s'adapter à
cette à cette donnée donc je crois
comprendre qu'il ait une priorisation et
c'est bien normal au regard du nombre de
vaccins à la la deuxième seconde le
second de doses pour les + 75 ans mais
dans le même temps d'ici quelques jours
quelques semaines j'étais avec les
médecins de la commune
au téléphone tout à l'heure pour faire
un point avec eux sur l'arrivée de faire
des dégâts dans la maison médicale donc
les médecins vont avoir dans quelques
jours je n'ai pas la date exacte mais
dans quelques dans quelques jours dix
doses par médecin par semaine dans un
premier temps puis ça va passer à 30
doses par médecin dans un second temps
et donc à ce moment là on verra comment
ça comment dérouleront les choses alors
justement vous parlez
damien l'eau chaude et plus de 75 ans
alors ceux qui ne résident pas dans les
ehpad semble est parfois les grands
oubliés en cette première salle de
vaccination dans les régions beaucoup
tentent d'obtenir des rendez-vous en
vain cette taxe est aussi le cas chez
vous bah ya beaucoup de huy pour les +
75 ans et un amour ou qui souhaitent se
faire se faire vacciner et qu'il
n'arrive pas aujourd'hui à obtenir
obtenir de rendez vous donc
effectivement c'est aussi une une
angoisse qui est partagé lorsque l'on
sort dehors pour parler avec les uns et
les autres et une angoisse qui est qui
remonte beaucoup parce qu'il ya une
vraie envie de vouloir se faire vacciner
pour une raison assez simple c'est pour
qu'une une vie des plus normal puisque
puisse revenir et au delà de la de la
maladie c'est élise allmand que les plus
de 75 ans vivent depuis maintenant
presque un an donc il faut bien avoir en
tête ça fait un an que les seniors de
notre pays vivent avec pas loin de leurs
familles loin de leurs proches loin de
leurs petits-enfants et ça commence
évidemment à peser très fortement sur le
moral des françaises et des pratiques
qui sont confirmés comment ça se
manifeste chez vous est ce que vos
administrés viennent
vous voir il ya de la colère de la
tristesse vous ressentez justement cette
lourdeur vous sur sur le terrain louis
est un mélange de tout vous avez des
lourdeurs vous avez de la tristesse vous
avez une forme une forme d'anxiété alors
nous on a mis en place différents
différente de faire on a mis en place
différentes comme les différents
dispositifs pour pour justement aller à
les voir aller voir les seniors quand on
recommande dans un dispositif qui
s'appelle présents pour vous on a un
agent communal qui va voir les personnes
âgées pour prendre de leurs nouvelles
pour échanger avec eux pour savoir s'ils
ont besoin de quelque chose de
particulier c'est un dispositif qui
fonctionne très bien donc
donc il ya beaucoup de travail cette ce
dispositif va s'étendre dans les dents
les semaines dans les semaines à venir
puisque ce contact avec les seniors est
évidemment absolument essentiel est donc
de savoir de ce qui se passe dans le ski
se passe dans la commune qui se passe
dans la collectivité d'avoir des
échanges
c'est extrêmement important pour eux
c'est extrêmement important aussi pour
nous parce que on a un vrai attachement
avec avec avec les seniors et
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile de ne
pas pouvoir passer du temps ensemble
avec quoi merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'amiens est louche maire ps d'epinay
est-ce que je peux rajouter jeu propre
et un sur demont parentèle puisqu'on a
parlé des anciens est extrêmement
important je voulais aussi avoir un mot
pour les étudiantes et les étudiants et
je voulais juste avoir cette réflexion
on parlait des anciens avec est en lien
avec le minimum vieillesse et je profite
du temps d'antenne qui met aujourd'hui
octroyés pour parler du minimum jeunesse
qui va devenir dans l'est dans les
semaines dans les mois à venir une
nécessité vitale absolue pour pour la
jeunesse de notre pays
donc l'idée c'est aussi d'avoir le
spectre le plus large dans cette
réflexion autour du pacte républicain du
socle républicain est à mon sens le
minimum jeunette est en est un est un
socle qui permettra justement de
sauvegarde et de ce pacte républicain
qui aujourd'hui est en danger merci
beaucoup damiano chat d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rtl france
la commission européenne elle a présenté
aujourd'hui sa nouvelle stratégie
vaccinale d'arc alors que de nombreux
pays peine à danser la leur la
présidente de la commission
ursula von der leyen s'est exprimée afin
de confirmer de nouveaux accords avec lé
laboratoire pfizer bio tech i moderna
pour la production de nouvelles doses
vaccinales
après avoir annoncé un accord pour la
production de 200 millions de dons
supplémentaires avec kasabian teched a
confirmé la demande de 300 millions de
doses supplémentaires à moderne
aujourd'hui la commission a approuvé un
second contrat avec moderna afin de
produire 300 millions de doses
vaccinales supplémentaires c'est une
excellente nouvelle
night in dc sco news et pour en parler
nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claudin blanchemaison alors
pourquoi la commission européenne prend
tel enfin le mors aux dents
la commission européenne est très
critiqué depuis un an et c'est un grand
classique alors à sa décharge on peut
dire que l'union européenne un peu de
compétences en matière de santé des
traités prévoit que cela relève surtout
les états membres sauf sur deux points
le premier c'est que depuis 25 ans il
existe une agence européenne des
médicaments qui est chargée de
l'homologation de tous les médicaments
pour ensuite ils puissent être autorisés
à être mis sur le marché sur le marché
unique de l'ue de l'union européenne et
puis la deuxième exception elle vient
d'une décision des états membres en juin
dernier un peu dans l'affolement de la
situation ils ont délégué à la
commission
la capacité de conclure des contrats
avec les
laboratoire qui auraient des vaccins à
l'époque en juin il n'existait pas
encore de vaccin
donc la commission a négocié avec six
laboratoires qui était de renvoi
d'arriver à un vaccin
trois d'entre eux ont obtenu
l'autorisation de l'agencé européenne du
médicament et par conséquent un milliard
de vaccins se sont retrouvées mises à la
disposition des états membres il y en a
à 2 milliards lorsque deux les trois
autres vaccins de laboratoire n'ont pas
encore l'accord de l'agencé européenne
de la santé auront l'agrément et puis il
ya eu ce marché d'aujourd'hui était
annoncé essentiellement avec modern art
qui ajoute à peu près 500 millions de
vaccins la population de l'union
européenne ces 450 millions d'habitants
donc en effet il semble que cela
convienne alors sauf que la petite
complication c'est que la commission n'a
évidemment pas les capacités logistiques
pour distribuer ses vaccins et donc ces
vaccins vont directement des
laboratoires la plupart du temps ceux
qui sont sur le territoire de l'union
européenne
dans les états membres et les amendes
ont un droit de tirage qui se traduit
par un droit d'achat qui est
proportionnelle à leur population par
exemple pour la france c'est 15 % du
total des vaccins achetés négocié par
contrat par la commission et donc nous
sommes dans ce schéma avec sans doute un
résidu de vaccin qui sera in fine et
acheter plus tard dans l'année par la
commission elle-même pour les pays
d'afrique et qui eux n'ont pas les
moyens de se fournir de vaccins sur le
sur le marché alors dans ces conditions
là évidemment la commission aujourd'hui
après une initiative majeure non
seulement pour annoncer le contrat que
vous avez décrit mais aussi pour
annoncer la création d'une nouvelle
agence
alors la commission justement dévoilé
claude blanchemaison un plan pour
préparer l' europe 1 c'est là
certainement vous faites allusion
un plan pour affronter les mutations du
covin baptisé ra en quoi cela va
consister à l'or grâce est un acronyme
pour elf est bien celle-ci response
maternity autant utile c'est
effectivement dans les pays anglo saxons
quelque chose qui correspond à une
agence et donc la commission propose ni
plus ni moins au conseil conseil
européen devraient en discuter le mois
prochain la création d'une nouvelle
agence
madame von der leyen a expliqué que
cette nouvelle agence aurait un aspect
scientifique et un aspect industriel
l'aspect scientifique c'est qu'elle sera
en mesure avec les scientifiques qui
travailleront de faire des séquençages
des des prises qui seront dès lors dès
lors des tests qui seront réalisées et
par conséquent de tracé très exactement
le développement des variants des
variants il y en a actuellement trois
mais ce pourrait caler davantage et
c'est eux qui ont le degré de
contamination le plus élevé est par
ailleurs à côté de madame dans l'airial
zaien se tenait le commissaire thierry
breton qui est français et qui s'occupe
du marché intérieur et des questions
industrielles
thierry breton peut-être plus prudent
mais plus concret a dit mais que d'ores
et déjà lui avait mis en place à une
task force
une task force industrielle c'est à dire
qu'il a réuni les industriels en état de
fabriquer des vaccins à l'intérieur du
territoire de l'union il a visité leurs
usines et qui l'est c'est qu'il
s'efforce dans le cadre de cette force
de faire que ça marche
et pour que ça marche il faut que ceux
qui entrent dans la composition des
vaccins soient disponibles en quantité
suffisante quelquefois ça vient de
l'extérieur de l'union européenne et que
tout ça puisse être fabriqués à temps il
faut aussi aider les entreprises en
question à faire les investissements
nécessaires pour accroître leurs
capacités de production et faire en
sorte que les quelque 16 ou 18
entreprises
ils sont capables de produire ces
vaccins dans l'union européenne le fasse
dans les meilleurs délais et en
accroissant leur production alors je
pense que
le conseil européen a va saisir de
l'ensemble de cette opposition
certains états membres et seront
immédiatement favorables d'autres
proposeront la question combien ça va
coûter
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment avoir des
scientifiques et des gens qui s'occupent
de logistique dans ce futur dans cette
future agence cette future autorité ou
est ce qu'il vaut pas mieux avoir une
task force qui coordonne les moyens
existants dans les états membres
ceci fera l'objet donc d'une discussion
au niveau des chefs d'état de
gouvernement
alors justement amplement je fais on
parle beaucoup des décisions prises au
niveau européen illustration avec cette
campagne de vaccination mais finalement
face au co vite quel bon niveau pour
prendre les décisions l'om est seule
l'union européenne ou peut-être trop un
petit peu plus bas les régions les
villes
évidemment les états ont joué un rôle
clé dans des situations de crise
ce genre de crises pandémiques de ce
genre puisque c'est eux qui détiennent
les moyens régalien et notamment usage
de la force publique pour faire
appliquer les décisions qui sont prises
que ce soient des décisions de
confinement des décisions de deux tests
des décisions de vaccination par
conséquent les états quelle que soit la
la capacité des autres institutions
garde un rôle clé mais évidemment au
niveau international vous avez vu
aujourd'hui que monsieur thiriez
secrétaire général des nations unies a
appelé à l'élaboration d'un plan de
vaccination mondiale et c'est pas c'est
uniquement pour des raisons humanitaires
et généreuse
c'est parce que si on veut éradiquer
cette pandémie il faut qu'elle soit
éradiquée par tous s'il ya des poches
des continents entiers comme l'afrique
où elle continue de se répandre
évidemment elle reviendra en europe et
dans d'autres régions
ensuite le ms l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
eh bien il est tout à fait logique aussi
qu'elle édicte des règles générales pour
une pandémie qui affecte l'ensemble des
pays les états jouent un rôle clé
madame merkel le montre bien mais il se
trouve que cela dépend aussi de
l'organisation interne des états en
allemagne il s'agit d'un état fédéral et
ce sont les länder calquella coup et qui
ont la compétence en matière de santé
donc la chancelière merkel passe
beaucoup de temps à négocier avec les
ministres présidents des différents
länder pour les convaincre d'adopter une
attitude commune et celle qu'elle
recommande au niveau de l'ensemble de la
république fédérale d'allemagne
et puis par ailleurs à un niveau
inférieur comme vous l'avez cité on voit
bien chez nous que les présidents de
région demande à avoir davantage de
responsabilités et beaucoup considèrent
que dans le fond les choses seraient
peut-être peu mieux conduit si on
donnait davantage de responsabilités aux
présidents de région en matière de tests
en matière de vaccination
on va dire aussi de gestion du niveau de
confinement et c'est la même chose aussi
pour certains maires qui demandent
davantage de responsabilités alors il
existe un principe pour mettre tout le
monde d'accord est un principe on essaie
d'appliquer entre les états membres et
l'union européenne
c'est le principe de subsidiarité ça
veut dire quoi ainsi de cette vérité ça
veut dire tout simplement
on essaie de prendre la décision au
niveau où elle sera le plus efficace
ce serait souhaitable qu'on le fasse il
est clair qu'en ce moment on ne le fait
pas très chaud
merci claude blanchemaison rester avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la proposition de la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
commander un rapport au cnrs / l'islamo
gauchisme au sein des facultés en france
depuis la polémique ne cesse d'enfler ce
qu nantais sqs une enquête
utile ou stériles comme le précise des
présidents d'université ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face
[Musique]
fin janvier des petits investisseurs
sont parvenus à se coordonner sur
internet pour faire plier de grands
fonds d'investissement rassurez-vous
vous avez quelques mains qui en ont bien
profité qui ont mis à genoux un album
mais comme comme on faisait déjà depuis
je vous dis 30 ans on la seule
différence est l'effet de foule s'est
organisée sur des réseaux sociaux donc
c'est un peu la version 3.0 des
opérations organisées entre
investisseurs ne faut pas considérer ça
comme la révolution des petits contre
les gros et c'est non cdti beaucoup plus
malins qui sont des grosses mains et qui
ont organisé leur coup on nous vend un
peu le conte de fées que c'est que des
sardines qui ont attaqué le requin est
en fait je pense que parmi les sardines
y avait aussi des records
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde le saurait
pas en appartement on est énervé dans le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vais vers mâcon il passe un tour
de tracteur avec une grande campagne il
faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 17 février la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur sous le feu des
critiques frédéric vidal a jeté un pavé
dans la mare avec son intention de
commander un rapport au cnrs / l'islamo
gauchisme au sein des facultés en france
les présidents de fac n'ont pas manqué
de réagir en fustigeant une nouvelle
polémique stérile sur le sujet le cnrs
dénonce ce soir une instrumentalisation
de la science alors y at il du
militantisme dans les universités ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face dans
quelques instants
aux etats unis donald trump s'en prend
aux chefs des républicains au sénat
mitch mcconnell est un politicien
renfrognée maussade avec qui les
républicains ne gagneront plus assène
l'ancien président donald trump qui
continue d'essayer de peser dans le
débat politique américain avec succès
selon certains sondages
les vaccins dans le monde et des
produits recherchés en europe des
produits rares parfois comme en afrique
l'om est-ce déplore que leur répartition
se fasse au détriment des pays les plus
pauvres en homologuant hier d'urgence le
vaccin anti qu'ovide d'astrazeneca
l'organisation ouvre la voie à la
vaccination des pays défavorisés
[Musique]
en france donc la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur sous le feu des
critiques frédéric vidal a jeté un pavé
dans la mare en cause son intention de
demander au cnrs un bilan de l'ensemble
des recherches qui se déroule en france
afin de distinguer ce qui relève de la
recherche académique et ce qui relève du
militantisme avec un objectif combattre
l'islamo gauchisme qui sévirait sur les
bancs des facultés selon l est les
présidents d'université eux font part de
leur stupeur le cnrs dénonce une
instrumentalisation de la science alors
une enquête sur l'islamo gauchisme l
université utile ou stériles les
universités françaises sont-elles
gangréné par l'esl m au gauchisme comme
l'affirment la ministre c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir pour en
débattre nous sommes avec emilie marsh
conseillère régionale la france
insoumise auvergne rhône-alpes bonsoir
emilie marsh à vos côtés kevin bossuet
professeur d'histoire en
seine-saint-denis bonsoir kevin bossuet
merci d'être avec nous alors c'est une
phrase un polémique donc de frédéric
vidal depuis dimanche soir je vous
propose tout d'abord de l'écouter avant
de vous faire réagir
je pense que l'islamo gauchisme gangrène
la société dans son ensemble et que
l'université n'est pas imperméable
l'université fait partie de la société
d'alors cabinet à bossuet on en a
souvent parlé puisque vous êtes de temps
en temps notre invité sur ces sujets
vous dénonciez souvent cet islam au
schisme qui règne dans les rangs de
l'éducation nationale il ya selon vous
une prise de conscience en tout cas ce
serait votre avis on imagine ce soir de
la part de frédéric vidal oui évidemment
une prise de conscience enfin on s'est
rendu compte que dans ce pays il y avait
un problème il n'y avait pas un problème
avec le christianisme il n'avait pas un
problème avec le judaïsme il y avait un
problème avec l'islam radical
cela fait des années en effet que la
france est gangréné par cette idéologie
est gangréné par ces gens qui détestent
la france
ceux qui détestent la république et
surtout qu'ils adaptent qui adoptent la
stratégie de l'anc triste c'est à dire
que le but c'est d'être présent partout
c'est d'être présent dans l'éducation
nationale c'est d'être présent dans les
universités c'est d'être présent dans
les associations dans les clubs de
football afin de répandre cette
idéologie et afin d'abattre la
république française et d'abattre la
france est évidemment que frédéric vidal
a raison de mettre en avant la montée de
l'islam au gauchisme au sein de
l'université
il ya des choses qui se passent dans nos
universités qui sont inacceptables moi
je me souviens qu'il y a deux ans à
l'université paris-x vite on avait
retrouvé des tables des tags qui
relevait du racisme anti blanc qui avec
des cales c'était mort aux blancs
français égale [ __ ] je suis trop blanc
faye touaibi pôle anti france vaincra
c'est quelque chose qui n'est évidemment
pas accès pas acceptable et même au
niveau des enseignements on voit bien
qui a une frontière qui n'est pas très
nette entre l'enseignement d'un côté et
le militantisme de l'autre il ya une
percée dans le monde universitaire de ce
qu'on appelle les études postcoloniales
qui voudraient notamment faire passer
l'occident pour pour une entité raciste
pour une entité suprématie ce n'est
évidemment pas acceptable
évidemment qu'il faut préserver la
liberté au niveau de la recherche
évidemment il faut permettre aux débats
au sein de l'université mais quand vous
avez une partie des enseignants qui est
terrorisée par une autre tout simplement
parce que l adapt elle n'adopte pas la
bonne idéologie il y à un véritable
problème donc lui il faut une enquête
il peut même aller plus loin une enquête
dont toutes les sphères de la société
pour vaincre l'esl a nice comme on a
essayé de vaincre le nazisme il y à
quelques décennies donc à vendre est
faire réagir un mini marche on va
écouter aussi l'un de vos tweets puisque
vous vous êtes exprimé sur les réseaux
sociaux genre de m'écouter à part
demandé la démission de frédéric vidal
et jean michel blanquer air que c'est
faire la gauche
pas grand chose oui il y à un islam au
gauchisme qui en train de ravager notre
société tous ces gens qui refusent de
condamner l'islamisme sont des dangers
publics
alors emilie marsh vous êtes la gauche a
en tout cas vous représenter la gauche
ce soit dans ce débat que répondez vous
à ces attaques
alors moi déjà six en graine dans
l'université actuellement ça s'appelle
la précarité étudiante parce qu'on a
quand même 5 étudiant sur sept qui ceux
qui s'estiment en difficulté de santé
mentale on a des étudiants qui sont dans
une détresse on a des files d'attentes
au niveau des banques alimentaires et
pour moi mon avis à la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur recherche
plutôt que d'aller chercher des
polémiques ou une chasse on se croirait
en plein maccarthysme ferait mieux de
s'occuper de haut niveau de ce qui est
en train de se passer dans une
université et de réouvrir les fac parce
que ce que demandent les étudiants et
les étudiantes en grande majorité
actuellement c'est pouvoir avoir des
cours avec un professeur est pas
forcément devant un écran
voilà moi je commence enfin en fait
c'est un débat voilà ça ça excite juste
quelques personnes alors qu'on n'est pas
en train de parler des sujets qui sont
en train de on est pas en train de
parler pendant ce temps là qu'on concret
c'est ces polémiques des entreprises qui
licencient à tour de bras de la deûle
amis de la précarité qui est en train de
s'installer non non on crée on crée des
polémiques et moi je suis assez en
accord avec le communiqué de presse qui
a eu la conférence des présidents une
universitaire quand même qu'on va pas
terminer un organe de gauche un cas qui
alerté par rapport à ça et aussi le
communiqué de presse du cnrs ou en plus
juste d'islam au gauchisme n'est pas un
concept scientifique et d'où une
ministre aussi va commander si elle veut
vraiment qui est plus d'enquêtés de
travaux scientifiques en sciences
humaines et sociales
elle ferait bien d'abord d'augmenter le
budget parce que depuis plusieurs années
quand même il est vraiment à la messe
justement on va l'écouter cette colère
des présidents d'université écouter
cette publie cette tribune pendant
qu'ils ont publiées
elle est intitulée islem au gauchisme
stopper la confusion et les polémiques
stériles
la cpu fait part de sa stupeur face à
une nouvelle polémique stérile sur le
sujet de l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université la cpu s'étonne de
l'instrumentalisation du cnrs
la cpu appelle à élever le débat le
débat politique n'est par principe à un
débat scientifique
il ne doit pas pour autant conduire à
raconter n'importe quoi
voilà d'où viendrait kevin bossuet ces
confusions auquel fait référence la
conférence des présidents d'université
non mais en fait il ya aucune confie
confusion ce sont des gens qui sont des
idéologues ce sont des gens qui sont des
militants et qui n'accepte pas en effet
quand on entre dans les universités pour
voir ce qui s'y passe vraiment vous
voyez par exemple votre invité moi je
pensais que la gauche bête et méchante
et est finalement morte et je crois que
finalement avec votre invité nous avons
une survivante puisqu'elle a passé quand
même le début de son intervention à nous
parler des problèmes sociaux ce qui est
vrai en effet il ya un vrai problème
social chez les étudiants qui sont de
plus en plus précarisés avec cette crise
de la cofidis up mais je ne vois pas le
sujet la vérité avec les militants de la
france insoumis ce n'est jamais le bon
moment pour évoquer les sujets liés
notamment à l'islam icc quelque chose
qui n'est évidemment pas acceptable
il y a dans nos universités un véritable
problème avec l'islam aux gauchistes
qu'est ce que c'est que l'islam aux
gauchistes c'est tout simplement des
gens qui refusent de condamner l'islam
radical boire qui se soumettent à cet
islam radical vous avez même dans
certaines universités ce qu'on appelle
de la censure quand vous avez sylviane
agacinski
la compagne de neige aux pins qui va
faire une conférence sur la gpa
l'université bordeaux i finalement que
sa conférence est annulée parce que le
sujet des plaies à une partie des
universitaires c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas acceptable c'est une forme de
censure donc à un moment il faut
peut-être prendre un peu consciente de
cela parce qu'il ya quand même qu est-ce
que quelques semaines il ya un
enseignant samuel patil qui a été
décapité
à quelques mètres de son collège pour
avoir défendu les valeurs de la
république au sein de l'institution
scolaire et quand j'entends certains
enseignants dans l'éducation nationale
où certains professeurs à l'univers
et nous dire que finalement ce n'est pas
très grave il faut passer à autre chose
ou que voire pire que samuel pattes ils
l'auraient bien cherché
ce sont 10 discours qui sont
inacceptables la vérité c'est que la
france insoumis c'est dans
l'électoralisme parce que tôt sur
certaines parties du territoire en effet
son beurre électoral elle le fait sur le
séparatisme elle le fait sur le
communautarisme et quand les caméras
sont ouvertes évidemment ils se disent
profondément républicain et quand les
caméras sont éteintes finalement on se
rend compte qu'ils ont des discours qui
sont pas foncièrement républicain a donc
à un moment j'en ai marre de cet écrit
cette extrême gauche qui est en train de
tuer notre république un moment il faut
un sursaut et je félicite madame vidal
d'avoir eu ce sursaut est d'essayer de
voir ce qui se passe vraiment dans
certaines parties de nos universités
emilie marsh clairement gaming bossuet
vous interpelle en tout cas vous vous
personnellement mais votre parti c'est
une réalité qu'il décrit lui rend tout
cas que vous n'y auriez à la france est
soumise
non on ne nie rien du tout mais c'est
pas en insultant tout le monde et une
population en islamo-gauchiste qu'on va
régler le problème qui assure sur sûr
le terrorisme ce qu'il faut ça c'est des
moyens est ce que c'est par exemple plus
de gens dans les renseignements d'ordre
dans le renseignement parce qu'au niveau
de la police au niveau des moyens
humains on en a de moins en moins mais
c'est pas en qualifiant en stigmatisant
en en envoyant toujours des termes et en
accusant et en accusant les autres en
fait on en fait je ne vous permets pas
je suis je défend la laïcité je suis je
suis la garde et que oui mais par contre
c'est bizarre parce qu'on on stigmatise
toujours une mais par contre quand moi
je vois la région 1 le président de la
région ainsi que que la droite et que
d'autres composantes se faire bénir
chaque année par monseigneur barbarin en
tant qu en tant qu élu de la république
1 pour les voeux à fourvière ça
bizarrement ça choque personne non plus
donc en fait non moi - nettement les les
opinions heureux enfin je je je ne
permets pas et ça m'énerve vraiment en
fait parce qu'il ne me connaît pas et
d'où ils m'attaquent widi d'autres non à
la france est soumise
nous défendons la laïcité la laïcité et
nous sommes profondément républicain
après honnêtement c'est vrai que on en
j'ai tout le temps peur en peinture
certain sens voilà par pur plaisir par
pur racisme en plus parce que ça ça des
rampes ici mais vous pouvez tourner la
tête mais six mois en fait ce que ce que
ce que je retiens c'est que moi je
trouve ça quand même extrêmement grave
que ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on a
des étudiants qui se suicident qu' il y
en a peut-être vous dire que tu la
survivante de la gauche mais je peux
vous dire que je suis peut-être pas la
seule survivante parce que ça choque
beaucoup de personnes que nous sommes le
pays qui est la sixième puissance
économique au monde et qu'on a des
étudiants qui sont en train de crever de
crever la dalle affaires ddd des heures
d'attentes pour avoir un paquet de pâtes
un paquet de riz est la seule réponse
qu'on a
de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur recherche 7 craignent qu'une
polémique sur son l'islamo gauchisme
franchement honnêtement je pense que vu
les urgences qui à haut niveau dans
l'université a ferait mieux de s'occuper
à trouver 900 millions d'euros pour
réouvrir les facs comme demande
les étudiantes et les étudiants parce
que là en fait ils sont enfermés au sol
juste les étudiants c'est les seuls qui
sont 36 23e confinement parce qu'ils
sont tous les jours en visio et caen et
quand arrive la fin des cours il est 18
heures et le couvre-feu
kevin bossuet est ce que vous vous
admettre triés par hasard que frédéric
vidal court un peu sur les sur les
terres du rassemblement national à un an
de la présidentielle
ce genre de sortie c'est ce
électoraliste pour vous mais absolument
pas frédéric vidal est une républicaine
comme jean michel blanquer est un
républicain et quand ces deux personnes
en effet met en avant l'
islamo-gauchiste ils le font tout
simplement pour servir la république
pour renforcer la république c'est quand
même incroyable qu'à partir du moment où
on attaque l'islamisme dans notre pays
on se fait traiter de raciste on se fait
traiter comme étant des gens
profondément d'extrême droite
j'entends votre intervenants qui nous
raconte qu'elle est laïque dans ce cas
là faut qu'elle change de parti parce
que quand je vois jean luc mélenchon lé
défilé dans cette espèce de
rassemblement de lutte contre
l'islamophobie à côté de gens qui sont
des islamistes
je vous prie de m'excuser mais ça
mettrait un petit peu et vous voyez
votre intervenante ne sait pas répondre
à la question à chaque fois elle dérive
soit sur les problèmes sociaux ou soit
elle nous met en avant la question de
monseigneur barbarin je ne sais même pas
qui est sanctionné même pas le sujet
voyez bien que votre interlocutrice est
en effet indisposé parce que tout
simplement on est en train de s'attaquer
de s'attaquer à une partie de son
électorat qui surf sur l'antisionisme
qui n'est en fait que le faux nez de
l'antisémitisme alors je ne dis pas que
la france ont soumis c'est un bar des
sports en fait c'est la raison de
dégueulasse et des françaises qui
habituent en territoire on sait
parfaitement je voudrais je vous permets
pas juste de dire ça et en fait c'est de
convaincre par nos propres valeurs et de
faire ensemble et c'est pas en
stigmatisant les gens cons
on y arrivera mais madame est un
problème sourit le fait madame
le problème c'est que vous le faites et
cécile mmm allons vous habite sur un
sujet et vous parlez en fait être
d'autres choses moi j'aimerais vous
poser une question est ce que vous
condamnez l'islamisme dans ce pays
oui ou non est ce que ça vous pose un
problème vis mais on me mets moi je
condamne toute forme e d'aurec et de
radicalité qui a dans n'importe quelle
des religions parce qu'en fait il n'y a
pas que le problème avec l'islam
donc nous avons aussi des radicaux au
niveau de l'église catholique
nous l'avons aussi dans dans d'autres
religions en fait est que je ne suis pas
pour en mettre plus une en avant que
qu'une autre adacore donc c'est quand
même on a en france un problème avec
l'islam radical et madame le problème
c'est le local kddi et que le problème
c'est le judaïsme
c'est complètement ridicule elle me fait
penser à aurélien dachier qui nous
parlaient qui comparaît notamment le
burqini à des serre têtes ou qu'ils nous
disaient au moment on allait s'occuper
de la polygamie dans notre pays qu'il ne
fallait pas le faire tout simplement
parce qu on rentrait dans le lit des
gens ceux d'histoire est tout bonnement
inacceptable vous avez un problème avec
la république un moment la france c'est
la récup égaliser maternité liberté
c'est quelque chose de très important
donc quand je vous demande si vous
condamnez l'islamisme et que vous vous
défausser pour me parler des religions
c'est qu'il ya un problème madame donc à
un moment donné si ce n'est pas le cas
alors qu'ils étaient dominés marche est
le mot de la fin
islamisme madame est ce que vous
condamnez la participation de jean luc
mélenchon à la marche contre
l'islamophobie aux côtés d'associations
en effet qui avait quand même des
accointances islamistes donc j'attends
votre réponse et le mot de la fin s'il
vous plaît me les marges
oui mais moi comme je viens de répondre
mais ça ne va pas vous plaire mais je ne
suis pas là pour vous plaire moi je
condamne toute forme
de deux radicalités qu'elle soit de
religion pas et que oui il faut il faut
la combattre il faut la combattre dans
les lois républicaines que en avant pour
faire vivre la république et faire les
faire vivre le vivre ensemble
mais ce n'est pas en stigmatisant
toujours les uns et on leur doit
évidemment évidemment tu les terroristes
il faut les combattre
évidemment que les terroristes il faut
il faut les combattre et vite avalées
par les islamistes puis des terroristes
donc en fait c'est vous qui êtes dans
les amalgames
c'est vous peut être dans la
stigmatisation quel est le lien entre
les deux merci en tout cas le privé de
compas tout terrorisme vous remettra pas
d'accord emilie marsh kevin bossuet ou
[Musique]
merci à tous les deux d'avoir été avec
nous d'avoir accepté en tout cas ce
face-à-face merci à vous et toujours en
france on trop sujet de controverse
l'écriture inclusive un député la reine
s'y attaque françois jolivet s'apprête à
déposer un texte pour interdire son
usage dans les services publics
depuis plusieurs années l'utilisation de
l'écriture inclusif fait débat certains
la trouvent à plus égalitaire d'autres
la jugent source de confusion les
explications
[Musique]
tous
non
[Musique]
et nous
plus
[Musique]
m
e
[Musique]
à la crise sanitaire en france nouveau
conseil de défense matin autour d'
emmanuel macron aucunes mesures
exceptionnelles annoncées mais le porte
parole du gouvernement en alerte
nous pourrions payer très cher tout
relâchement gabriela talent qui est
aussi revenu sur la stratégie de
vaccination du gouvernement
les précisions de notre reporter david
khalifa un cap qui ne changera pas
malgré une très légère amélioration de
la situation sanitaire en france le
porte parole du gouvernement a salué l
les efforts des français qu'ils
encouragent à maintenir durant cette
période de vacances scolaires aucune
nouvelle restriction ne sera prise même
dans les zones où le variant est
inquiète afin je cite de laisser
respirer les français concernant lé
chiffre dans les hôpitaux ils sont en
baisse est la décroissance de malades du
comider de 14 % sur la semaine
le nombre de malades est dans un état
grave se stabilise et le nombre de morts
sur sept jours en moyenne on représente
1 300 décès quotidiens autre point
abordé par le porte parole du
gouvernement
la campagne de vaccination qui fait tant
polémique à gabriel attal a reconnu elle
qu'elle ne correspond pas à la volonté à
des français mais que le gouvernement
allait prendre toutes les dispositions
pour répondre à cette demande écoutez je
veux dire aujourd'hui que la mécanique
est bien en route les centres de
vaccination couvre tout le territoire et
nous fonctionnons en flux tendu nous
avons avec l'europe su taper du poing
sur la table et obtenu davantage de
doses de vaccin le président de la
république a mobilisé toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique et dès le mois prochain
des vaccins moderna seront fabriqués et
produit en france à la suite de cette
mobilisation
les trois quarts des résidents en ehpad
ont reçu une injection et déjà plus de
20 % des plus de 75 ans ont reçu au
moins une dose du vaccin
nous allons répondre à l' enthousiasme
nos aînés et puis par tranche d'âge
ensuite nous étendrons la vaccination à
l'ensemble des français selon le
calendrier la stratégie qui ont été
prévus et annoncés par le gouvernement
près de deux millions cinq cent mille
personnes ont déjà reçu une première
dose de vaccin soit 3,3 pour cent de la
population a contrario un peu plus de
900 mille personnes ont reçu la deuxième
dose un rythme qui doit donc à
s'accélérer à rien peut tout faire
basculer c'est sur ce terme précis des
cabris à la tall a insisté
c est pour cela qu aucun un changement
de cap n'a été abordé les français sont
nombreux à se demander quel camp ils
vont pouvoir retrouver une vie normale
malheureusement à ce n'est pas pour tout
de suite le couvre feu qui devait à la
base d'urée à quinze jours devrait
rester en vigueur il ne sera pas
modifiée tant que la situation le
nécessitera
on se dirige vers un allègement pas à
pas on se concentre en premier lieu sur
les départements les moins touchés
certains membres du gouvernement
attendent par exemple revenir sur la
réouverture ailes de certains lieux
publics comme les musées à compter du
mois de mars
en revanche pour les restaurants et les
centres commerciaux de plus de 20
millimètres carrés qui sont toujours
fermés ça ne sera pas avant l'été à 2021
selon un certain elle députés bref vous
l'aurez compris le bout du tunnel n'est
pas pour tout de suite
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de donald trump qui s'en
prend aux chefs des républicains au
sénat à l'ancien président continue
d'essayer de peser dans le débat
politique américain avec succès selon
certains sondages
et puis nous évoquerons la répartition
très inégale des vaccins dans le monde
qui se fait au détriment des pays les
plus pauvres selon l' oms ce qui risque
de prolonger les peelings
[Musique]
des accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve était
le seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
la minustah elle compte au moins
quatorze mille militaires et policiers
déployés au mali ou non s'est elle fasse
c'est une mission de paix et la chose
unis mais la vérité c'est qu'il évolue
dans un environnement difficile quand on
vend un ennemi un ennemi invisible
un élément qui ne connaît pas de
frontières qui ne connaît que la
brutalité qui est là pour faire du mal
mais grâce à notre détermination nous
sommes très différents
on a le sentiment c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes
quel est votre constat la menace et le
risque d'une menace plus bas et que sa
réponse également doit être vue sous
l'angle de la solidarité
robin
non
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que des gants dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sap est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur yann moix peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et dans l'hymne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for books les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dole à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata passe à papa parents
patin patin
vous avez envie de faire ça mais il faut
que leur qu'istres groove la musique
c'est la traduction la plus poétique de
la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie des vides à
mon sens bête il faut sortir les notes
de leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france donald trump sort de son
silence
libéré de la procédure de destitution
l'ancien président américain a publié
cette nuit un communiqué incendiaire
vis-à-vis de mitch mcconnell leader de
la minorité républicaine au sénat
il appelle les républicains se retourner
contre lui il faut dire que ce dernier
avait accusé publiquement l'ex-président
américain d'être responsables de
l'assaut meurtrier du capitole l'élu du
kentucky avait néanmoins voté contre la
destitution de donald trump lors du
procès au sénat et coûter
mitch et aux politiciens renfrognée
mossad qui ne sourit jamais et si les
sénateurs républicains restent avec lui
ils ne gagneront plus le parti
républicain ne pourra plus jamais être
respectées ou fort avec des dirigeants
politiques comme mitch mcconnell aux
commandes
maintenant ces chiffres dans les
sondages sont encore plus bas que jamais
auparavant
il détruit le côté républicain du sénat
et du même coup fait terriblement de mal
à notre pays et la cote de popularité de
donald trump toujours aussi hot selon un
sondage politique aux 53% des électeurs
républicains disent qu'ils seraient
prêts à voter pour donald trump 81% non
une pompe union positive et 59 %
seulement qu'ils jouent un rôle
important dans le futur politique de son
parti et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis houston aux états unis
avec dave perkins analystes politiques
militants pro trump c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors ce
sont d'argent qui montre que 59% des
électeurs républicains veulent voir
jouer un rôle important à donald trump à
d'avenir ça veut dire que malgré les la
charge de certains républicains donald
trump finalement ne ressort pas vraiment
affaiblis bien au contraire de cette
séquence de procédure d' impeachment en
fait
l'hostilité envers 30 de la part de
l'establishment américain montre que
donna très peu est sur la bonne voie
pour rester populaire encore plus
populaire auprès de la base électorale
qui se méfient de plus longtemps de ces
républicains et donald trump se sent
libérée et dit la vérité sur ces
républiques
il a vu la lettre montrant ce que te
trompes avait à dire concernant orange
mcconnell maintenant qu'il n'est plus en
poste et elle n'est plus lutter par un
besoin mais round de rester unis il peut
dire ce qu'il pensait beaucoup de
personnes me demandent va-t-il se
représenter à la présidence en 2024
maintenant que deux tentative de
destitution empêcherait équipe je pense
que demain 30 he corée kim a à des
saisies lors des saisons dans la vie
d'un homme est que cette saison est
passé il aurait presque 80 ans en 2024
et bien que joe dalton soit lui aussi
très âgées pour donald trump je pense
que c'est vraiment trop haut trop âgés
d'autre part il est très bon avec les
médias il a réussi à se faire entendre
il ne prend les genres bruce quoi il
réussit à provoquer du changement avec
ses paroles
donc je pense qu'il aura un rôle
important dans l'immédiat surtout en
cette période où elle habitait qu il
sert dohin refouler la version la vraie
version des faits les grandes
entreprises n'y a pas essai de faire en
sorte qu'un seul aspect de la vérité
soit évoquée en public et je pense que
dans 1 30 mètre je dirige
de ceux qui essayent de dévoiler la
vérité sur le monde politique je pense
tous les plus appropriés pour lui de
travailler dans nos médias et cours à
faire une différence dans le monde sans
être en politique
alors vous vous dites ça il percute mais
tout de même aujourd'hui donald trump
s'attaque clairement à mitch mcconnell a
on le rappelle le chef des républicains
au sénat est ce que c'est une simple
vengeance ou tout de même il voudrait
veut bien donald trump reprendre ce
parti républicain pour le restructurer
décroît de la vengeance c'est tout
simplement la vérité pour jeunes a tramp
ce n'est pas une période une personne
rancunière il ne dit que la vérité sur
mitch mcconnell
quel film dit mcconnell la crise a
ajouté qu elle de voir arriver une
nouvelle génération de dirigeants
cela fait des années que dirige au sénat
lorsqu'il écoute ce qu'il avait à dire
contre donald trump lorsque prennent
pour des cons ces menaces on se rend
compte que la loyauté de mekla tu
connais l'envers de nha trang et cours
de son mandat et quel faux sites au
cryptage pour faire mes choix que l'on
préfère de loin ses avantages ses
intérêts plutôt que de servir le parti
et dont un troc et donald trump se
comporte de la même façon envers leach
mâconnais quelle mouche mcconnell s'est
conduite envers lui en corrigeant ses
quatre vérités finale trump est à la
tête d'un mouvement de masse républicain
est républicain au pouvoir à washington
dc en sont très conscients et ils sont
terrifiés non pas que de nha trang
province mais que donald trump devienne
une voix dans les médias qui détournent
les électeurs républicains du parti
alors justement ces divisions que l'on
voit déjà depuis plusieurs mois poindre
au sein du parti républicain est ce
qu'elle pourrait entraîner la formation
d'un nouveau parti
selon vous où ça va être plutôt
compliqué dans les prochaines
année pour le parti républicain c'est la
fédé c'est nous qui joue avec 75
millions de personnes a ajouté je pense
d'ailleurs que beaucoup de gens et votre
repos bien mérité mais c'est un nombre
très important et c'est une occasion
unique pour former un nouveau parti
cela a été possible niveau administratif
cela fonctionnait bien on est si ce
parti était fait pour les élections de
2024 alors ils dépasseraient
instantanément le parti républicain mais
je ne pense pas que c'est ce que je ne
souhaite pas je pense qu'ils préfèrent
leur parti républicain soit retombée aux
mains des gens qui ont voté pour donald
trump qui veulent que le pays soit
dirigé selon les principes de la
constitution et les principes fondateurs
américains
il faut savoir que aujourd'hui ce sont
des gens lundi une commande électrique
dans ce qu'ils peuvent diriger votre vie
pour vous tenir un peu de décentraliser
le pouvoir qu'ils revoient now 50
hectares et le parti rue burqa on ne
peut pas supporter l'idée que les
électeurs républicains pourrait vouloir
retirer du pouvoir à washington
pourtant c'est ce pour quoi la vérité et
c'est pourquoi tu marconnelle est
toujours au pouvoir il ya bientôt 80 ans
mais ne peut pas renoncer au pouvoir
je ne pense pas que donald trump va
créer un nouveau parti je pense qu'il va
soutenir des candidats alternatifs au
sein du parti qui pourrait changer le
parti de l'intérieur justement c'était
ma prochaine questions qui pourraient
être ses candidats équipe pour vous vous
en avez peut-être une idée déjà dave
perkins pourrait porter le mieux votre
parti républicain je ne vais pas évoquer
des hnwi particulier pour le contrôle et
le sénat
cela reste encore à déterminer il faudra
voir qui est riche ou a remporté les
élections et qui s'opposera aux élites
c'est faux mais pour qui la présidence
mon premier choix et j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir même si cela pourrait
ressembler un peu monarchique
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir et je suis très
conscient des capacités et des idées de
nha trang junior et je pense qu'il
pourrait faire un magnifique président
il a fallu aux douches l'a fait pourquoi
pas la famille trinquent doute mon choix
pour le prochain président des états
unis c'est que donald trump junior en
tout cas c'est ce que j'espère bon vous
aurez encore 1,82 djahida houadef
taquine sens désolé pour vous mais voilà
je vous l'annonçais peut-être ce soir
merci à vous en tout cas d'avoir été en
direct pour re vu de l'extérieur
réunion au sommet autour de la question
syrienne à sotchi en russie des
délégations russes iraniennes et turques
se réunissent pour discuter de l'avenir
du pays en présence de l'onu du
gouvernement syrien et de l'opposition
dix ans après le début de la guerre les
chantiers politiques et sécuritaires
sont nombreux et précision de notre
correspondant à moscou antoine clairon
dans un communiqué commun les trois pays
garants du format d'astana soit la
russie la turquie et l'iran ont réitéré
leur détermination à combattre le
terrorisme sous toutes ses formes et
lutter contre les tentatives de
séparatisme visant à remettre en
question l'intégrité du territoire
syrien
les représentants de ces trois pays ont
exprimé leur préoccupation concernant le
sort des civils dans la région d'idleb
et ont appelé toutes les parties à
respecter le cessez le feu dans cette
zone il s'agissait là de la 15e
rencontre dans ce format qui a pour
objectif une résolution politique à ce
conflit qui dure déjà depuis dix ans
l'aboutissement de ce processus reste un
défi de taille tant les intérêts des
différents acteurs impliqués peuvent
diverger aussi la russie s'est dite
disposée à travailler avec toutes les
parties souhaitant réellement mettre fin
à ce conflit y compris les états unis
nous sommes donc tout à fait ouverts au
dialogue avec nos partenaires américains
aujourd'hui comme je le dis
pour l'instant la position de washington
sur le dossier syrien n'a pas été
formulée de façon définitive donc et il
faudra peut-être un peu plus de temps
mais ceci dit nous espérons quand même
qu'il y aura un intérêt et un dialogue
constructif de la part des américains si
effectivement ils sont et sont ils se
disent prêts à slab il a également été
question des élections présidentielles
qui doivent se tenir cette année en
syrie un scrutin que les autorités
russes estiment légitime et appropriée
au contraire des pays occidentaux qui
conditionne en grande partie l'aide
qu'ils peuvent apporter à la syrie au
départ de bachar el-assad la position
occidentale kg c'est à dire que toute
élection serait illégale cette position
est inacceptable donc nous considérons
que le processus politique de réforme
constitutionnelle doit se faire
parallèlement au fonctionnement normal
et habituel des structures de l'état
[Musique]
encore une fois sans intervenir dans les
relations dans dans la situation
intérieure au pays ne concédant que les
élections présidentielles ont lieu
d'être
on l'aura compris la résolution
politique de ce conflit s'annonce encore
longue et fastidieuse mais au moins pour
le moment la diplomatie prime
il sera d'ailleurs de nouveau question
de ce sujet complexe demain à l'occasion
de la rencontre à moscou entre le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
et l'envoyé spécial de l'onu pour la
syrie le marathon judiciaire continue
pour alexeï navalni elle est cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
ordonné sa libération avec qui fait
immédiat moscou de son côté est clair il
n'y a aucune base légale dans le droit
russe pour une libération c'est un
nouveau bras de fer donc entre européens
et russes après la visite et les
demandes de sanction du chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell
envers la rue
s'il y a un peu plus d'une semaine
moscou dénonce une ingérence grossière
et une décision politique
c'est une ingérence manifeste est
flagrante dans le fonctionnement du
pouvoir judiciaire d'un état souverain
deuxièmement cette demande est
injustifiée illégitime puisqu'elle ne se
référa aucun fait aucune règle de droit
qui permettrait au tribunal de prendre
une telle décision
la demande de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme était pertinemment
impossibles à satisfaire puisque
conformément à la législation russe
il n'y a pas de fondement juridique pour
remettre cet individu en liberté
l'exécution de cette décision de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ne
serait que la manifestation d'une
approche sélective ce qui va à
l'encontre du principe fondamental du
fonctionnement de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme quel état de droit
alors que les alertes se multiplient
depuis le début de la campagne de
vaccination certains pays pauvres
notamment en afrique n'ont pas accès à
suffisamment de doses pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire
pendant ce temps les états les plus
riches commande parfois jusqu'à quatre
fois plus de doses que leur population
mais une injustice dénoncée par des
organisations et les chefs d'état le
point avec florian lambert favoriser un
accès plus efficace aux vaccins pour les
pays les plus pauvres
voilà une des missions rappeler à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce par
sa propre chef
alertés par une campagne de vaccination
quasi inexistante dans certains pays
notamment sur le continent africain
la directrice générale de l'om c'est
entend venir en aide aux plus démunis
contre la pandémie de communisme
elle a d'ailleurs appelé à ce jour je
cite la mise en place d'un plan de
vaccination
il y a deux aspects la question de santé
publique et la question économique sur
la santé publique j'ai expliqué que je
crois que nous pouvons travailler plus
vite pour sauver des vies afin que des
pays n'est pas attendre des années avant
d'avoir accès au vaccin sur l'économie
le commerce a clairement un rôle à jouer
dans la relance il ya en ce moment dans
le monde plus de 60 pays qui vaccinent
alors que les autres ne le font pas
c'est vraiment dans l'intérêt de chaque
pays que tout le monde soit vacciner car
personne n'est en sécurité
tant que tout le monde n'est pas en
sécurité car dans les régions du monde
les plus modestes
la situation demeure alarmante malgré le
lancement par l'onu du mécanisme kovacs
dont les effets ne seront probablement
pas visibles à court terme
au grand dam de l'om et je dois être
franc le monde est au bord d'un échec
moral catastrophique et le prix de cet
échec sera payé par des vis et des
moyens de subsistance dans les pays les
plus pauvres du monde
lors du forum économique mondial de
davos le 27 janvier dernier le président
sud africain avait fustigé tout
nationalisme dans les stratégies
d'acquisition du vaccin les pays riches
de ce monde ont acheté de très grandes
quantités de vaccins
certains quatre fois plus que ce dont
ils ont besoin
nous leur disons mettez à disposition
les doses excédentaires que vous avez
commandé est mise de côté
il n'y a absolument aucune raison pour
qu'un pays de 40 millions d'habitants
hachette 120 millions de doses
l'organisation des nations unies
s'inquiètent elles aussi du fossé qui
s'était élargie entre riches et pauvres
l'instance a indiqué en décembre que 32
millions de personnes à travers le monde
avait basculé dans la classe de
l'extrême pauvreté en 2020 en raison de
la pandémie
un bilan appelé à s'alourdir si la
situation sanitaire ne s'améliore pas
rapidement dans de nombreux pays de
l'hémisphère sud
réécoutez justement à ce propos emmanuel
macron qui dénonce une crise
inacceptable des inégalités
à la crise sanitaire est en train de
s'ajouter une crise inacceptable des
inégalités aujourd'hui et une crise
sanitaire supplémentaire demain en effet
la lenteur de la campagne vaccinale dans
les pays pauvres et en particulier sur
le continent africain est absolument
inexplicable et intolérable et pour en
parler nous sommes avec sa y avait nos
experts de l'union africaine en
télémédecine président du conseil
médical de la société nem sookie bonsoir
ça il y avait
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france sont bien d'écouter des propos d'
emmanuel macron c'est inacceptable cette
inégalité vous partager ce sentiment du
président français oui je partage ce
sentiment mais le problème aussi reliés
à ce sentiment c'est que qui peut agir
dans ce sens parce que quand on prend
les et les gouvernements dans une bonne
partie du gouvernement qui sont
eux-mêmes désemparé n'arrivant pas à
avoir les doses qu'il leur faudrait pour
la population
donc du coup les autres des pays
africains qui rien ne bouge pas ça
devient un problème et comme on dit
souvent la main qui donne est toujours
en dessous de celle qui me soit ça c'est
que c'est assez difficile puisque les
pays africains n'ont pas contribué à ça
la solution serait que les hommes
politiques c'est à dire les décideurs
aient la force d'agir
or il me semble que dans le contexte
actuel ils sont un peu lié ils n'ont pas
toutes les mains libres
donc pour cent mais sinon je suis
entièrement d'accord avec son hôte
c'est une forme de démagogie entre
guillemets de la part du président mais
kron qui effectivement fait face à des
difficultés puisqu'il ya une énorme
pénurie caractérisée de doses de vaccins
en europe également et qui d'une
certaine manière semble s'offusquer
qu'il n'y ait pas assez de vaccins en
afrique de la démagogie vous interpréter
ça comment quand vous l'entendez le
président français quand je l'entends je
ne peux pas dire que c'est de la
démagogie parce que bon il le semble se
battre aussi pour son pays pour avoir ce
qu'il faut mais de l'autre côté en tant
que président français il fait partie de
haut niveau mondial de paris salon par
exemple nations unies ou de loin metz où
il parle aussi au nom d'une population
beaucoup plus large que la population
africaine
donc de ce fait il est dans son rôle de
constater que effectivement il ya une
zone de la planète qui fait reste qui se
trouve être un désert en termes de
vaccins il est dans son rôle de le
constater
mais maintenant ce que je dis aussi
c'est que ce rôle là et ce double rôle
qu'il a à disposition il devrait
l'utiliser pour influences ir pour
les organismes pour qui cela puisse se
réparer mais ce que je dis comme constat
c'est que quand vous prenez les les big
pharmas à toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique y sont pas prêts du tout
a lâché quelque chose là qui ils sont
plus manipulés par la bourse qui
s'affolent par le financier qui fait que
le vaccin qui il ya un des ministres et
d'ailleurs qui avait proposé que ça
pourrait être un bien public et ce
vaccin qui a été financée en partie par
les fonds publics
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui parler dans
le cerf un bien public
c'est pas possible donc ça ce sont des
choses qui ne peuvent venir que par les
autorités qui ne peuvent venir que par
des dirigeants d'un président comme
macro comme un glas merkel ou tous les
autres dans le film y compris le russe
n'est pas ce que c'est
tout ceci là qui sont des voix pourtant
qui te fait en sorte que cela et puis se
passer on imagine que l'union africaine
a pensé à cette question est ce que
l'union africaine a su parler d'une voix
pour tenter d'approcher tous ses
laboratoires comment elle procède
l'union africaine dans ce domaine au
niveau de l'union africaine visant le
centre de contrôle des maladies et
lucide et cie qui est basée à addis
ababa au siège même de l'union africaine
qui collabore étroitement avec les
différents ministères de la santé et en
particulier avec le ms aussi donc
mais ce sont des institutions qui n'ont
pas à eux de l'argent apprendre à lâcher
et donner ce sont des institutions un
peu comme le ms qui sont sous les ordres
il exécute les ordres des chefs d'état
et pour exécuter ses ordres et leur faut
de l'argent pour pour la mise en oeuvre
et fêtard a également donné par les
différents états donc ils peuvent parler
mes filles n'ont pas les moyens d'agir
ils pourront toujours continuer de
parler donc au niveau de l'hygiène
africains leur couleur politique a été
dès le départ de pouvoir avoir un
minimum de vaccins pour chacun des pays
africains et de pouvoir les étudier le
problème qui se pose aussi c'est que il
ne faut pas que tout le temps la
décision ce soit du top down c'est à
dire dont le dissident haut et puis on
impose les pays africains ils ont une
expertise évidente et je pense que le
problème c'est que les niveaux des
autorités ils ont été très
en paris ça a laissé les médecins
africains travailler et donc il faut les
laisser travailler
il faut les laisser définir leurs
besoins comme ici on la sait on a
classifié par exemple la population est
aujourd'hui en sursis qui meurent le
plus ce sont les personnes les plus
âgées
on peut commencer par vaccinés à ce
niveau là donc chars pays pourrait
définir ses besoins pour cette tranche
de population pour la première vague et
ensuite il prévoir les seconds zag en
fonction du taux de létalité décès qui
se passe dans la paix ils ont eu
beaucoup une bonne expertise et il
faudra aussi qu'on travaille maintenant
à leur donner une sorte d' expertise
locale parce que tout le temps attendre
que le nord fabriqué en mai nous que le
nord d'essayer de caisse qui est bien
pour eux alors qu'il ya une expertise
locale qu'on peut utiliser le sommes
dans une pandémie qui montre que nous
sommes tous dans la même case que nous
sommes tous sous le même le même arbre
donc ça veut dire que il faut que les
moyens de production aussi soit un peu
disent pâtir pour qu'eux aussi puissent
réagir en matière en matière même de 25
et quitta produits c'est un accent local
montre que ça puisse être utilisable ce
qu'elle a toujours eu des millions des
millions de vaccins pour être débattue
aujourd'hui peut-être il y en aura deux
perdues ne comprend pas conserver
comprend pas transporter et il y aura
même de fond d'accent qui vont commencer
à bâtir et à circuler parce que les gens
vont les fabriquer puis pouvoir avoir de
l'argent clairement quel est l'état des
forces en présence si j'ose dire
on imagine que c'est assez compliqué
selon les pays mais
il y a quand même des campagnes qui ont
bel et bien débuté avec succès des
campagnes qui a débuté avec chips et
surtout au maroc par exemple où il
annonçait les ont faits des vaccinations
et l'afrique du sud c'est un cas
particulier parce que l'afrique du sud
c'est vraiment comme on le dit un état
arc-en-ciel fava delà du développement
le plus performant comme en europe d'ici
à là pour respecter la plus extrême donc
c'est une étape essentielle c'est pas
toujours évident de le prendre comme
référence bain par exemple au sénégal
ils vont ils vont commencer aussi il ya
eu le malawi qui est l'incarnation et de
la majorité la majorité d'entre eux
utilisent le chinois sinovac
d'autres comme le maroc la tunisie ont
également commandé des doses avec chez
les russes donc en fait celle ci qui ont
un peu plus de moyens qui ont déjà
commandé leur propre doses pour
commencer la vaccination
les autres ont pris des contacts mais
n'ont pas encore reçu ou comment dire
une plateforme pas commander d'abord de
l'action alors le mot location hier en
urgence par l'om est d'astra zeneca
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour pour
l'afrique
alors pour l'afrique la bonne nouvelle
ce serait un bastien facilement maniable
je pense que on a aussi embarqué pour
beaucoup de choses à chercher les
vaccins qui vont jusqu'à 95 100 % tous
les vaccins qu'on a utilisées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
dès qu'il atteint 60 % d'efficacité on
est content on les a toujours utilisé
jusque là alors vouloir un vaccin qui
fait du 95 94 pour ça et sans avoir les
moyens de l'utiliser dans les conditions
définies par le fabricant c'est une
utopie ça sera finalement ça sera
finalement criminelle puisqu'on a
injecté de l'eau à des gens en disant
qu'ils font vacciner donc l'afrique
devrait s'orienter vers des vaccins qui
peuvent manipuler c'est à dire dont ils
ont les moyens de conservation et toute
la logistique qui va avec pour permettre
de matinée
le nombre de personnes qui vont que lui
de vacciner merci beaucoup
bonne chose qu'il ait plusieurs vaccins
mais écoute chaque pays pourra faire son
choix en fonction de ses moyens
merci beaucoup ça y avait à nous d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur r
france et c'est la fin de cette émission
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
un point complet de l'actualité avec
pierre pissavy yvernault
[Musique]
fin janvier des petits investisseurs
sont parvenus à se coordonner sur
internet pour faire plier de grands
fonds d'investissement rassurez-vous
vous avez quelques mains qui en ont bien
profité qui ont mis à genoux un iphone
mais comme comme on le faisait déjà
depuis je vous dis 30 ans la seule
différence est l'effet de foule s'est
organisée sur des réseaux sociaux donc
c'est un peu la version 3.0 des
opérations organisées entre
investisseurs ne faut pas considérer ça
comme la révolution des petits contre
les gros et c'est non cdti beaucoup plus
malins qui sont des grosses mains et qui
ont organisé leur coup on nous vend un
peu le conte de fées que c'est que des
sardines qui ont